yeah um you got me drunk on your late
night shows so it's only fair we'd a
drink on my daytime show great so RH
drink
it's themed to a different area of your
life oh that's so exciting
no first I know you had specialty drinks
for the best here as well first up we've
got the lucky 7 in honor of the seventh
season of Late Night with Seth Meyers
[Applause]
late nights need caffeine a shot of
vodka to help you get through political
jokes okay this is just so much
potential there's so much absolutely to
pull from my knee to shot gold flakes
for the glitzy Hollywood actors on your
show and it's on the rock since you tape
a 30 rock okay okay here we go
[Applause]
[Laughter]
don't challenge me cuz I'm so
competitive and I don't want to go home
here this is a real there's a real milky
drink I know I think I might get upset
telling you from that one yeah mm-hmm
aside from me who was your most
memorable get it I told you're in
competitive okay weight or weight you
throw and I'll try and catch it you
think that's a better idea yeah okay are
you ready
like here's the zone the zone how do you
think in general
I love it when we get together we just
do like fraternity games yeah I'm gonna
say do they usually do the interviews go
off the rails this quickly well yes okay
yes good going how it usually does I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this